slash shop and click on book tv
next on public lives paul oster editor
of i thought my father was god and jack
lyden of national public radio host a
reading of 15 selections from the
anthology which compiled real-life
stories submitted by npr listeners to
the national story project
during this hour and a half event you'll
hear from several of the authors and a
few celebrity readers including joan
allen john tutturo and author susan
sontag
good evening
i'm dean ulcer of the wnyc program the
next big thing
[Applause]
thanksgiving is weeks away still but
i'm not going to be waiting until then
to give thanks
i've come specifically tonight to give
thanks for a variety of things
first of all to you
in the audience
on behalf of wnyc
because i know that many many of the
people in this room
took part in that unprecedented
financial contribution to the radio
station to help pay for the replacement
of our fm transmitter
which used to broadcast from the top of
the world trade center
and jackie and paul in fact are donating
their fee from tonight
to that fund
the silencing of wnyc signal
however temporary was
the loudest possible reminder we could
have
of just how urgently we need to hear
stories
for that short time
the camp fire was doused and the nights
were just too quiet to bear
we needed more than ever to hear stories
from the people who are paid to tell
them
but also from the people who are not
and yet have much to say
very often with wit
and grace
and best of all surprise
now long before september 11th the
people in that second category
the people who are not paid
were given a place on national public
radio to tell their stories
thanks to writer paul oster and weekend
all things considered
the national story project is one of the
best examples ever
of why what we do is called public radio
this series of stories
which was curated by paul became a book
tonight the radio series the book become
part of this
celebration of new york city
and so as i said i'm here to give thanks
to you and the audience for your
humbling generosity
to robert pulido and the new school for
making the event possible
to paul oster who reminds us every time
that we read his words
why we love to live in new york and to
paul's npr collaborator jackie lydon who
i ask you now to welcome to the stage
thank you dean also
also a former collaborator and and uh
it's so great to see so many of you
coming together on this this evening you
know i have been with national public
radio uh for what i say is you know the
better part of my adult life and we'll
just leave it at that
and it's it's been certainly the longest
relationship i've ever had
and usually
we go out and we ask you for your
stories we sift for the jewels we find
in your words and we bring them back to
weave into the tapestry that we hear on
the radio
when npr's weekend all things considered
interviewed paul about his latest novel
tim book 2. uh he and my colleague danny
zwardling who was hosting the show at
the time hit it off so well that danny
found himself saying hey why don't you
come and tell some stories for us on the
radio
and i like hearing paul tell tell the
story because what he he always says
then is i thought that was a terrible
idea
we've kind of won him over now
he went home and he shared that idea
with his wife the writer siri husvet who
will also be reading tonight and she
said you know you don't have to tell
these stories yourself
you could have the listeners tell them
you know as a longtime radio host what
is so exciting for me is that we have
had a chance to hear from our listeners
in a way that i don't believe national
public radio has ever been able to do
before
and it became like opening a gift box uh
we would start the
we would announce that we wanted the
stories on the first saturday of the
month
then uh then paul would receive
thousands of letters or we would in the
end it was five thousand letters the
producers rebecca davis and davar
ardalan at weekend all things considered
uh would set everything up and then paul
would walk in with this uh you know just
sheaf of gold under his arm
it's a great pleasure to now be able to
meet some of our contributors in person
to share those stories about new york at
this time in new york's history and i
think to consecrate them uh
in a way that brings us all together to
remember that while these stories are
amazing the act of sharing with us
sharing them with us on the radio says a
lot about what i think is the special
magic of radio its ability to be the
alchemy of the imagination i know that's
why i've hunt around so
thank you again so very much and i'd
like to introduce
my collaborator and the editor of i
thought my father was god paul loster
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you jackie thank you dean
before september 11th my plan was to
turn this event for the national story
project into a new york evening a
celebration of the spirit of new york
now eight weeks after that terrible day
my plan is still the same
more than ever it is the same
over the past two years i've read more
than 5 000 stories sent in by npr
listeners from all parts of the country
early on i noticed a distinct and
surprising trend
new york is the only city in america
that anyone wants to talk about
we might not be a part of america
but we are in the eyes of an astonishing
number of americans
what america is all about
more than just a place more than just an
agglomeration of people
but an idea
crazy new york fractious new york ugly
new york beautiful new york
wounded new york
funny new york resilient new york
impossible new york
nearly every one of the stories you will
hear tonight is set in this town we all
love so much
this laboratory of human contradictions
some of them will be read by the authors
themselves
others will be read by guest readers
writers actors artists each one a
citizen of new york
we have a very full program
so without further ado i'd like to
introduce our first reader edith marks
who will be reading her own story new
york stray
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening
in one of my moments of despair
following my husband's death
i decided to go to a play
hoping
that a night in the theater would lift
my spirits
i lived in the east village
and the theater was on 34th street
i decided to walk
within five minutes a mongrel dog
started to follow me
it did all the things a dog normally
does with its owner
exploring some distance away
and then running back to check on his
companion
i became intrigued by the animal
and stooped
to pet it
but it scampered away
some passes by also seemed to be taken
with a dog
and tried to coax it to come to them
but it ignored them
i bought an ice cream cone
an office some to the dog
but it still wouldn't come to me
as i approached the theater
i wondered what would become of the dog
just before i entered
it finally approached me
and looked me
full
in the face
and i saw the compassionate eyes
of my late husband
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much edith marks our next
contributor is joel einschlag and joel
is going to read his story dead man's
bluff
[Applause]
hello
dead man's bluff
when i was growing up we lived in a tiny
apartment in queens
it was in a new building surrounded by
vacant lots
my father had brought us to this barren
land to escape the lower east side of
new york
now the hip is part of gotham
my birth had been the impetus to get us
near the suburbs
every friday night my father's friends
would come over to play cards
the living room would be transformed
into a busy street corner
in a two-bedroom apartment with two
sisters i always slept in the living
room
on fridays when pinacle was played into
the early morning hours i stayed up
pretty late for a ten-year-old
my father would set up a temporary bar
in the kitchen
seltzer soda scotch and rye
a tray of ice cubes alongside the
bottles
you take a coaster and mix yourself a
drink
my mother would cut up a pineapple and
decorate the plate surrounding the
yellow slices with red cherries
she'd make it look like a boat ready to
sail away
i would hang around the men a student
ready to soak up everything the
professors could teach him
smoke hovered over the car table in big
clouds
leo gold always blew these serene
slow-moving smoke rings
when the rings broke up and drifted away
the game would begin
once the cards were dealt everyone would
dig in
it became so silent you could hear the
ice melting in the glasses
i loved to watch my father work the
cards
they became alive in his hands his
dexterous fingers shuffling and dealing
with perfect precision
the sounds and rhythms hypnotize me
every time
the man who blew smoke rings leo gold
was my father's favorite pinocchio
player
my father played cards with leo for more
than 20 years
i grew up got married and raised a
family and my father became a frail old
man
eventually he was admitted to a nursing
home
when i went to visit him if he wasn't
too tired we played cards
it paid me to see my father with her
away but cards remained a lifeline for
him
one saturday after an afternoon of poker
my father seemed happy
i kissed him and said goodbye
he died the next day
the burial was a long distance away out
on long island we followed my father's
hearts in a limousine such a strange
time to sit in luxury it was a warm and
beautiful summer day
friends and relatives gathered at my
father's gravesite his pine box was
lowered into the ground
i put the first shovel full of dirt onto
his coffin
when i looked up from the grave sunlight
streamed into my eyes
i blinked
then i noticed that the stone next to my
father's grave bore the name leo gold
could this be the leo from the card game
i took a step back to where my mother
was standing and leaned toward her
leo gold is here i whispered
with tears in her eyes she scanned the
crowd where's leo she asked i don't see
him
no mom i said he's lying next to dad
leo gold carved in granite just a few
feet away from my father the two of them
lying side by side in a cemetery in the
middle of nowhere
my mother cried if this is our leo then
daddy won't be too lonely out here
at least they can play cards
i smiled thinking about life's tricks or
was it death's tricks
that evening my mother called leo gold's
number we learned from his wife that leo
had died about six months earlier and
that he was in fact buried in the same
cemetery
thanks
our next reader uh will be joan allen
reading a story written by laurie pikoff
table for two
[Applause]
okay
in 1947
my mother deborah was a 21 year old
student at you at new york university
majoring in english literature
she was beautiful fiery yet
introspective with a great passion for
books and ideas she read voraciously and
hoped one day to become a writer
my father joseph was an aspiring painter
who supported himself by teaching art at
a junior high school on the west side
on saturdays he would paint all day
either at home or in central park and
treat himself to a meal out on the
saturday night in question he chose a
neighborhood restaurant called the milky
way
the milky way happened to be my mother's
favorite restaurant
and that saturday after studying
throughout the morning and early
afternoon she went there for dinner
carrying along a used copy of dickens's
great expectations
the restaurant was crowded and she was
given the last table she settled in for
an evening of goulash red wine and
dickens and quickly lost touch of what
was going on around her within half an
hour the restaurant was standing room
only
the frazzled hostess came over and asked
my mother if she would be willing to
share her table with someone
barely glancing up from her book my
mother agreed
a tragic life for poor deer pip
my father said when he saw the tattered
cover of great expectations
my mother looked up at him and at that
moment she recalls she saw something
strangely familiar in his eyes
years later when i begged her to tell me
the story one more time
she sighed sweetly and said i saw myself
in his eyes
my father entirely captivated by her
presence
swears to this day that he heard a voice
inside his head
she is your destiny
the voice said
and immediately after that he felt a
tingling sensation that ran from the
tips of his toes to the crown of his
head
whatever it was that my parents saw or
heard or felt that night
they both understood
that something miraculous had happened
like two old friends catching up after a
long absence from one another they
talked for hours later on when the
evening was over my mother wrote her
telephone number on the inside cover of
great expectations
and gave the book to my father
he said goodbye to her
gently kissing her on the forehead and
they walked off in opposite directions
into the night
neither one of them was able to sleep
even after she closed her eyes my mother
could see only one thing
my father's face
and my father who could not stop
thinking about her stayed up all night
painting my mother's portrait
the next sunday he traveled out to
brooklyn to visit his parents
he brought along the book to read on the
subway but he was exhausted after a
sleepless night and started feeling
drowsy after a few paragraphs so
he slipped the book into the pocket of
his coat
which he had put on the seat beside him
and he closed his eyes
he didn't wake until the train stopped
at brighton beach at the far edge of
brooklyn
the train was deserted by then
and when he opened his eyes and reached
for his things the coat was no longer
there
someone had stolen it and because the
book was in the pocket
the book was gone too
which meant
that my mother's telephone number was
also gone
in desperation
he began to search the train looking
under every seat not only in his car but
in the cars on either side of him in his
excitement over meeting deborah joseph
had foolishly neglected to find out her
last name
the telephone number was his only link
to her
the call that my mother was expecting
never came
my father went looking for her several
times at the nyu english department but
he could never find her
destiny had betrayed them both
what had seemed inevitable that first
night in the restaurant was apparently
not meant to be
that summer
they both headed for europe my mother
went to england to take literature
courses at oxford and my father went to
paris to paint
in late july with a three-day break in
her studies my mother flew to paris
determined to absorb as much culture as
she possibly could in 72 hours
she carried a coffee along with her of
great expectations a new copy for the
trip
after the sad business with my father
she really hadn't had the heart to read
it but now as she sat down in a crowded
restaurant after a long day of
sightseeing she opened it to the first
page and started thinking about him
again
after reading a few sentences
she was interrupted by a maitre d who
asked her first in french and then in
broken english if she wouldn't mind
sharing her table
she agreed and then returned to her
reading
a moment later she heard a familiar
voice
a tragic life for poor dear pip
the voice said
and then she looked up
and there he was again
thank you
thank you joan
that was wonderful our next reader will
be art spiegelman and he is reading
danny kowalski
by charlie peters
[Applause]
[Music]
these are glasses i use to find the ones
i read with
in 1952
my father quit his job at ford to move
us to idaho and start his own company
instead he got polio and spent six
months in an iron lung
after three more years of therapy we
moved to new york city where my father
finally got a sales job this time with
the english car company jaguar
one of the perks of the new job was a
car that he was given to drive
it was a two-tone gray jaguar mark 9 the
last of the elegant rounded models it
looked like something that belonged in a
movie star's garage
i was enrolled at st john the evangelist
a parochial school on the east side with
an asphalt playground separated from the
street by a high wire fence
every morning my father would drop me
off at school in his jaguar before
heading off to work
being the son of a blacksmith from
parsons kansas he was proud of his car
and thought i should be proud to be
driven to school in it
he loved its genuine leather upholstery
and the small burled walnut tables that
were attached to the backs of the front
seats on which i could finish my
homework
but i was embarrassed by the car
after years of illness and debt we
probably didn't have any more money than
the rest of the mostly working-class
irish italian and polish kids in the
school but we had a jaguar and so we
might as well have been rockefellers
the car separated me from the other kids
but especially from danny kowalski
danny was what they called a juvenile
delinquent in those days
he was slight and had a mound of blonde
hair sculpted with grease and spray into
a tsunami-like pompadour
he wore the shiny pointed boots we
called puerto rican fence climbers
his collar was always up and there was a
permanent practiced snarl on his upper
lip
it was rumored that he had a switchblade
maybe even a zip gun
every morning danny kowalski would wait
in the same spot at the school fence and
watch me as i climbed out of my two-tone
gray jaguar and entered the schoolyard
he never said a word he just stared at
me with hard angry eyes i knew he hated
that car and that he hated me and that
someday he was going to beat me up for
it
my father died two months later we lost
the car of course and soon i'd have to
go live with my grandmother in new
jersey
mrs richfield an elderly neighbor
offered to walk me to school the day
after the funeral
when we approached the schoolyard that
morning i could see danny hanging on the
fence same place as always his jacket
collar turned up his hair perfectly
quaffed his boots recently sharpened
but this time
as i passed him in the company of the
this feeble elderly woman with and with
no elitist english car in sight i felt
as if a wall had been taken down between
us now i was more like danny more like
his friends we were finally equals
relieved i walked into the schoolyard
and that was the morning danny kowalski
beat me up
[Applause]
uh the next reader will be nelly rifler
who's the assistant editor and help me
at every step of the way in putting the
book together and nelly is going to read
a story written by
catherine austin alexander who now lives
in seattle washington
called dancing on 74th street
[Applause]
hi
manhattan
august 1962.
a hot afternoon my third day here
the studio apartment is scorching
with a hammer and a screwdriver i chisel
paint from the only window
then with one great shove i push the jam
to the top and turn my head toward the
unbroken line of brown stones
next door
neighbors are fanning out to the stoops
where a brown skinned infant curls its
lip and arches its back before mama
offers her nipple
in turquoise pants and clear plastic
pumps she sits cross-legged dangling her
shoe from her toes a newspaper between
her and the hot cracking cement while
the newborn draws its milk
mama alternates between a thin cigar and
a bottle of cerveza
papa in his undershirt swaggers out with
a radio in one hand and a toddler
dragging a broom in the other
the tot begins sweeping the stoop but
changes its mind and strums the bristles
instead
kitchen chairs are being carried out
along with six packs of tab 7up and
rhinegold
i'm getting a whiff of black beans and
saffron rice steaming from the hibachi
under the stairs
mama ties back her brash red hair plops
the baby in a box from gristiti's market
and slowly begins to twirl her hands on
her waist
she stops
slinks over to her man
and with her knee
nudges his thigh
grinding to the sounds of the caribbean
the pair dodge plunge twist and swerve
the child accompanies with a wooden bowl
and spoon his father smiles in approval
flashing a gold incisor
bongo players expand along the pavement
while the new one sleeps in a cardboard
box
and i
a girl of 20
a year out of nebraska
watch transfixed
suddenly papa with the flashing incisor
looks up from the pandemonium to my
window hey muchacha he yells to me you
gotta smoke
[Applause]
our next stories from a listener who
recently read his story on weekend
authors considered reginald fair from
palisades new york is going to read his
story the celebration
[Applause]
good evening
it's nice to know that a bunch of
amateur authors can fill the hall like
this
the celebration
august 14 1945 vj day
the day japan surrendered ending world
war ii
i was stationed at an air base on the
outskirts of sioux falls
south dakota
we received word of the surrender late
that afternoon
and immediately just about everyone on
the air base headed into town to
celebrate
there weren't nearly enough jeeps and
trucks so most of us hitchhiked
how peaceful it was
as we passed through the gently rolling
farmland
with a few cows munching munching away
under a sky that was bluer and brighter
than ever
with a few puffy white clouds that were
whiter and brighter than ever
what a wonderful state of affairs
i had flown and survived
79
combat missions over europe without a
scratch
would not have to fight in the pacific
and would soon be going back to college
at columbia
after four years of military service
the world was at peace
and i was headed into town
into town
to celebrate
i have trouble controlling my breath
when i got there the celebration was
well underway
thousands of soldiers had gathered in
the center of town
along with hundreds of
civilians
liquor was flowing freely
as the celebration progressed i bought a
bottle of beer
and made my way up to the roof of a
one-story building
joining a group that was observing the
wild noisy scene below
grateful civilians were hugging and
kissing the soldiers
and thanking us for winning the war
a farmer arrived
in a battered old pickup truck and
immediately and unwillingly sold the
truck to an intimidating group
of drunken soldiers
who had passed the hat
for the donations to pay for it
the fire department arrived quickly
with sirens shrieking
thank you
with sirens shrieking
hooked up their hoses and were promptly
overpowered by the mob
that grabbed the fire axes and severed
the fire hoses
as the fire consumed the truck
the crowd
including soldiers civilians and even
firemen roared their approval
as the center of the action sifted down
shifted down the block
i came down from the roof and followed
the drunks got drunker and noisier and
what has started out
as a joyous celebration
of the end of the bloodiest
and most terrible war in history
in the history of mankind
became a wild chaotic
violent scene
store windows were smashed
and fights broke out
the few policemen on hand
were
powerless to bring order to the
situation
it didn't even appear that they wanted
to
a scuffle broke out involving six or
eight white soldiers
pummeling a black soldier
there were shouts of kill that [ __ ]
kill that black bastard
he managed to break free
and run up a side street with a look of
stark terror on his face a look that
i'll never forget as long as i live
the mob pursued him
brandishing empty whiskey bottles
to the black soldier's surprise
he found that the
side street was the dead in an alley
dead in the alley and there was no way
out
i felt that i should go to his rescue
but i was afraid of the mob
as soon as he reached the end of the
alley he turned faces pursuers and stood
wedding there for their
waiting for their next move
he was dripping with sweat
the look of horror terror on his face
became a look of steely determination
pursuers all came to an abrupt halt
except for one soldier
who advanced toward him
took a swing at him and got the surprise
of his life
when he
was knocked out flat with one punch
stepping over the unconscious body of
his assailant the black man clenched his
fists and said i'm leaving now
there was total silence
everyone stepped aside
and they let him go i was tempted to
congratulate him but i was afraid he
would say where were you when i needed
you
that after that i lost interest in the
celebration and hitchhiked back to the
air base
thinking about that ugly incident
i felt guilt excuse me
i felt guilty that i had not gone to the
man's defense
that guilt reminded me of something i
had once read in a short story
a man watched in silence as another man
is lynched in the deep south
he is at once shocked and fascinated by
what he has witnessed
the mob disperses
leaving the corpse dangling from a tree
limb
and the man and the man walks home
ashamed of himself
for having been too afraid
to intervene
when he walks in the door
his wife noticing the look of guilt and
shame on his face
blurs out you've been with a woman
haven't you
[Applause]
uh the next reader is uh the person who
came up with the idea for the national
story project i'm very grateful to her
for that and many other things
siri who's fit
[Applause]
[Music]
oh dear
there
i've gotten far too much credit for this
but
i'll tell you it's a lot easier being
amused than
being a writer
i'm reading heaven
by grace fichtelberg
who lives in rancho status new mexico
this happened to me when i was six years
old
i'm now over 75 but it's as fresh in my
mind as if it happened just yesterday
my sister dottie was eight years older
than i was and she was responsible for
taking care of me after school
she hated having to do this
but i loved going along with her when
she visited her friends
one afternoon
dottie had to go to another girl's
apartment to do a homework assignment
and dutifully dragged me to the building
and up three flights of stairs
i knew that i was going to be bored
when they did homework in the kitchen i
was neglected in every way
the two of them would giggle and ignore
me
they called me brat and pest and often
teased me to tears
on that particular afternoon
i had nothing to do after all i was only
six years old
i tried to get their attention but they
were hard at work and wouldn't look over
at me
so i decided to have a fit
i just laid down on the floor and
started kicking my feet i screamed i
banged i made all the noise i could
the tenant in the apartment below
couldn't tolerate the noise and so she
grabbed a stick and started banging on
the ceiling
that frightened me but i stubbornly
continued to kick and scream
what a horrible noise i made
but my sister went on ignoring me and
she and her friend just laughed to show
how little they cared about what i was
doing and the lady below
in her second floor kitchen
kept
banging up and screaming at the top of
her lungs
finally
i stopped crying out of pure exhaustion
but the lady kept banging on her ceiling
i could feel the vibrations in my body
and then i heard her scream i'm coming
up you'll be sorry when i get there
my sister and her friend panicked
and so did i
dottie grabbed my hand pulled me to the
door and opened it listening to make
sure that the woman wasn't on her way up
to the landing
shut up she said to me and then she gave
me a pinch on the arm to make sure i'd
behave i was so scared i was whimpering
but she kept pinching my arm until i
calmed down
as we stood there on the landing
listening for signs of the woman i could
feel dotty's body shaking with fear
we couldn't leave the building by going
down the stairs because that would have
meant passing in front of the woman's
door
dottie was worried that she was waiting
for us
the only way out was to go
up the stairs
she pulled me up to the fourth floor to
the fifth floor to the sixth floor
and then we came to a steel door
luckily for us she was able to open it
we went out onto the roof of the
building
but i didn't know this
i had never been on a roof before and i
didn't know where we were
i didn't know
what this place was i remember that we
climbed over walls running from one
rooftop to another
then dottie stopped at another steel
door and opened it and guided me down
the stairs to safety
we stepped out onto the sidewalk
of this strange block
i don't know why
not even to this day but when our feet
touched the sidewalk
i thought
we'd gone to heaven
i imagined that we were in heaven
i looked around and was amazed to see
children jumping rope
just like we did and that everything
looked the same
except how could that be
when this was heaven
when we turned the corner i could see
stores and people going into them and
out of them carrying bundles
and i was amazed
so
this is what heaven looks like
i said to my sister but she wasn't
listening
every new block was more exciting to me
than the last
i figured we'd reached heaven by
climbing up the stairs and crossing over
the rooftops
i was so happy to be there
where children played like me
then we turned one more corner and we
were on the block
where we lived
how did our street get up to heaven
i asked my sister but she didn't answer
me she just pulled me in through the
door of our building and said shannon
i kept
this experience to myself for many years
it was my secret
i truly believed that i'd been to heaven
only i couldn't understand how i'd
gotten there or
how i'd found the way back to my house
this happened in the bronx
we lived on vise avenue
[Applause]
after siri i need to do a little
adjustment here
although you'd hardly notice
our next story is by sandra waller who
is a new yorker she lives here in the
city and her story is early arithmetic
[Applause]
good evening
okay
thanks
sometimes i went with my mother to the
street of stores
really there were hardly any stores
there there was hardly anything in the
place where our store once stood and now
there is nothing
only a highway where cars streak madly
on their way the endless rushing past of
the cars and the place where i walked
with my mother
i put my hand in hers and over us i see
the drifting branches of the trees and
hear the leaves in their green murmuring
a canopy over us as we go along
and the travel agent looks up from where
he sits on a straight back chair reading
the hungarian newspaper nape
looks up to wave at us in his window the
picture of an ocean liner faded blue and
red no one we know ever goes on an ocean
liner but still the picture is there a
reminder of possibility that can visit
us at any time
my mother carries her purse she calls
her satchel always have a clean
handkerchief whenever you go any place
she tells me
we are going to buy what she calls rat
cheese and i think it must be the
favorite of the rats
but
but it is for the cheese sandwiches my
father sells along with coffee and
newspapers the daily mirror and the
daily news the bridgeport post in the
hungarian paper
no one ever reads the new york times
candy store owner says my father when i
ask him what to tell the teachers when
they ask for information for the school
records
but that is not all he
sells that is not all we are
and where is your father's business the
teachers ask
they want the numbers the exact address
for the records they say will follow us
throughout our lives
but i can never keep the numbers in my
head
the corner of cherry and pine is what i
tell them but because it is words that i
can remember
and i love to say the words together
cherry and pine cool northern forest
where we have never been
and cherry like the smith brothers cough
drops in the candy case
red and sweet but not as good as black
licorice with the taste of darkness on
your tongue
and not as good as hb cough drops
hospital brand i read on the box because
i'm always reading everything i see
words are like food and heir to me
and my mother tells me to stop reading
so much because it don't pay to be too
smart
look for where the blue dodge is parked
i could tell the teachers he drives it
forward every morning i hear his steps
clumping down the back stairs
resenting this interruption of my dreams
the early morning hours are the best he
tells me
look for the blue car of my father and
there you will find the place of soda
water and jujubes in the candy case i
have dusted with the rags of old
undershirts he gives me
jujubes with the taste of perfume like
jewels that stick in your teeth and i
just got your teeth fixed says my mother
only she pronounces it which is without
the th sound the teachers have told me
is so important
i could tell them i don't know the
address but find my way there every
afternoon like a sleepwalker going under
the railroad tracks and then past the
clanking factories until i see before me
the green faded awning with our name in
white black letters
the stone step of my father's store and
the wooden screen door with holes for
the flies to fly through
but this is not what they want of me it
is the numbers i can never remember
i can't count back to give change the
way he showed me
don't let the kid near the register the
customers tell my father
how can i add up the dimes when the thin
face of the man pictured theirs is
everything we will never be
someone who has power over us i can tell
just by the look of him there polished
and thin
the customer slapped their change onto
the counter and i see the buffalo on the
nickel his head bent toward the grass i
can feel it under my feet as i am
transported to his place of prairies
open land for miles where i can feel the
strength of the sun and the buffalo
ignores me like the customers their
heads bent to their coffee and
newspapers intent and separate in their
places in the counter
i try not to disturb them as i sweep
unobtrusively around their feet the way
my father showed me
numbers are what i need if i am to
succeed in the world that is something
everyone knows
but no one ever mentions the real nut
life of the numbers that i see before me
so clearly
no one ever mentions this in school
how i see the numbers as they go
one with his power who dares to start
off the long line of the numbers in
their march but he is alone
oh one with no one to go with him what
good is all his power if he is alone
not like lucky two part of a pair not
odd but even
dangerous three with x-rays of
electricity flashing around him
flash gordon death rays to kill even
mingle malevolent ruler of the universe
three like richie swenson who sets fire
to the waste paper baskets and gets
expelled so we will not have the danger
of burning up
four eyes he calls me what's new four
eyes he says
richie swenson expelled and free like
the buffalo to roam the streets will
never be like four
fat and comfortable and safe
five is a red convertible and six is
downtrodden has to work overtime
seven is infinite sorrow of that i am
sure the sorrow of the world heavy on
your shoulders old overcoat of sorrow
you can't shrug off i wish i didn't have
my knowledge of the sorrow that is seven
i wish i could cast it off but it is
with me forever
knowledge of the infinite sorrow of the
world that is contained in the number
seven
eight is reliable and dull but we'll
never know seven's power
nine is very smart but it doesn't matter
nine can never be happy and ten rules
them all lives on a hill in the better
part of town
how can i add or subtract them meddle in
their lives if johnny has 10 apples and
jimmy takes two how many will johnny
have then oh johnny how did you get so
many apples in the first place
johnny in your big house with all of
your apples that come to you so easily
jimmy down and out no apples in the
family
what of the perfume of the apples they
are lined up on the windowsill in the
attic room where my aunt sleeps green
and golden delicious are their names she
has them lined up because she says it is
a wonderful thing to sleep in a room
that smells of apples
in the attic room i read all the stories
in her citizenship book one after the
other
mabel listen to this child read says the
note the second grade teacher gives me
to take to the fifth
i keep failing arithmetic she must be
stupid everyone says i believed them all
thank you
[Applause]
uh the next reader will be peter carey
who will be reading a story written by
ludlow perry who lives in ohio
and it's called my mistake
[Applause]
i was driving day shifts for a yellow
cab company in dayton making a meager
hourly wage
it was the summer of 1966.
the city was in the grip of a heat wave
and everyone was irritable including me
[Music]
on this afternoon i was sitting at a
downtown cab stand in front of the
biltmore hotel
a large elegant place that was just
slightly past its prime
i had all the windows rolled down to
catch any breeze in the still air
i was hoping to get an airport run
instead i got a call from the dispatcher
over the radio he told me to go to
wilkie's newsstand and buy a racing
gazette
then i was to stop at the liberal market
downtown and pick up six bottles of
shirling beer
a small shaker of goldfish food
and a box of white owl cigars
no substitutions were permitted
and i was to use my own cash to pay for
the goods
the customer would reimburse me so
i was to save the receipts
he then directed me to deliver the goods
to apartment 3b at an address on third
street
which i recognized as an apartment
building
in a deteriorating neighborhood
i protested not wanting to lose the
chance for an airport run but also not
wanting to lay out money from my own
cash supply
because i was afraid i might not be able
to collect or worse
that i was being set up for a robbery
the dispatcher dispatcher now growing
impatient told me that this man was a
regular customer that there would be no
problem with payment and that i should
get moving or bring the cap back into
somebody who would
since he put it that way i got moving
privately though i cursed the customer
i figured he must be some kind of
welfare bummer was too lazy to feed his
own goldfish
and to procure what he needed to satisfy
his own vices
he infuriated me it infuriated me to run
these errands for someone who judging
from where he lived
couldn't possibly have enough money to
pay me
i drove to wilkie's and bought the
racing gazette
then down the street to liberals for the
goldfish food beer and cigars
then i drove up to the customer's
address it was an old 1890s four-story
dark brick apartment building
in a nearly livable condition
i entered smelling the stale tobacco
smoked tobacco smoke bacon and mildew
that are always present in such places
when i reached the third floor hallway i
knocked on the dark hardwood door of
apartment 3b
there was no immediate answer
i could hear something moving across the
floor
but it wasn't
footsteps finally the door opened but i
saw no one
no one that is until i looked down
there sitting on a small plywood
platform and looking up at me
was a man
he had a slight build and thinning black
hair
and he was wearing a white t-shirt and
grey wool pants with a thin black belt
at the waist
he had only stubs for legs
about as long as my hands
he was a double amputee who moved about
his one room apartment by propelling
himself on a small platform across the
bare wood floor
he held a rubble rubber cylinder in each
hand to push himself along
they were almost as big as mallet heads
with rubber rings on top for handholds
the man was polite and very grateful for
my services he directed me to put the
beer in a small frigidaire a relic from
the late 1940s
and to leave the cigars on the
kitchenette table
the goldfish were in a bowl there and he
asked me to feed them
then he asked me to put the racing
gazette on an old glass coffee table in
front of the worn couch
i did everything he asked gladly
i wasn't feeling irritable anymore
when i set the racing gazette down on
the coffee table i noticed an open
velvet case so it looked like a jewelry
box
as the man rolled over and reached for
the money he was going to pay me with i
looked inside the box
inside was a slightly tarnished medal
a purple heart
it was almost certainly from world war
ii since the man seemed to be in his mid
50s
guilt began to creep over me as the man
paid me for all the supplies and the cab
fare
then the guilt settled in when he gave
me a generous tip
much more than i would have made on any
airport run
the man was a quiet sort of person
obviously not in need of companionship
once our business was done
he showed me out
he had long ago reconciled himself to
his condition and to the sacrifice he
had made
he had no use for sympathy and didn't
offer any explanations
i would make that run many more times
until i moved on
but i never learned the man's name and
we never became friends in spite of our
regular contact
unfortunately for me
i would be more than twice the age i was
then
before i learned that pre-judging people
makes one wrong about most things most
of the time
[Applause]
our next story is by another new yorker
julianna nash and her story is called
snow
[Applause]
wow with my irish storytelling mother
who raised six native new yorkers
love this night
snow
i knew it was snowing before i opened my
eyes
i could hear the sound
[Music]
i start again
i knew it was snowing before i opened my
eyes
i could hear the sound of shovels
scraping against the sidewalks
and there was that special quiet in the
air that comes when the city is heavily
blanketed with snow
i ran to the window in the front room to
have a look at my block
my domain
it must have been very early none of my
friends had made it to the street only
the janitors were moving about
in the knee deep snow
relieved that i hadn't missed anything i
became aware that my sisters and
brothers
were now awake
i had no time to waste if i hurried i
could be out there before any of my
friends
i dressed myself in an assortment of
hand-me-down winter woolens
but there would be no mittens to keep my
hands warm i had lost them earlier in
the season
i was in a real dither as to what to put
on my feet my shoes no longer fit into
my rubber galoshes i could wear shoes or
galoshes but not both
i decided to go with two pair of socks
and the galoshes
as i was buckling them i felt the
presence of someone standing over me
it was my big brother lenny
he asked me if i wanted to go to ice
skating
at the indoor rink in madison square
garden
i immediately scrapped all other plans
my 13 year old brother was actually
asking me
his nine-year-old sister to go ice
skating with them
go of course i would go
but where would we get the money
lenny said it would cost the whole
dollar
to get in and rent the skates
only two obstacles stood between me
and going skating with my brother
the blizzard of 1947
and one dollar
the blizzard i could handle it was the
dollar that presented the problem
the quest began
we returned some milk bottles asked mama
for a nickel baked pop of a quarter a
piece collected a penny or two from coat
pockets
discovered two coins that had rolled
under the beds
and spotted a rare stray dime
in the corner of one of the six rooms in
our cold water railroad flat
eventually
fortified with a bowl of hot oatmeal and
jamming the hard earned coins into our
pockets
we set out on a 20 block journey
a city mile
the wind-driven snow clung to every
surface
lenny and i pretended that we were in
the alps as we climbed over three-foot
mounds of snow that had been shoveled to
the curbs
it was our world now
a myriad of tiny snowflakes had shut
down the city
and kept the adults indoors
the skyscrapers were invisible behind a
white veil of snow
and we could almost imagine
that new york had been scaled down for
us
we could walk right up the middle of
third avenue with no fear of being run
over
it was hard to contain our joy
the incredible sense of freedom we felt
out there in the snow
the 12 blocks to 49th street weren't
difficult but the long crosstown streets
proved chilling the harsh winds blowing
off the hudson river made it almost
impossible to push forward
i could no longer keep up with my
brother
my playful imaginings were replaced by
the gnoring cold of my feet
my head was uncovered my
mitten-less hands
sorry
then you'll see my hands are shaking
okay
um
i lost it i was dyslexic
help me
my mintless hands were clenched in my
pockets and a few of my class on my
galoshes had broke loose worked loose
i began to complain gently not wanting
to make a nuisance of myself because i
was afraid that lenny wouldn't ask me to
go anywhere with him ever again
somewhere near fifth avenue we stopped
in a doorway to take refuge i timidly
told lenny that my class were open
lenny took his bare red hands out of his
pockets and bent down to refasten the
snow-crusted
icy metal clasps
a shame that lenny had to take care of
me i stared straight ahead
and saw the image of a man walking
towards us
through the chiffon curtain of snow
i was unable to tell how old he was all
adults seem the same age to me but he
was tall
then
and he had a gentle handsome face
he wore no hat
there was a scarf around his neck and
his overcoat like ours was caked with
snow
i don't remember if he spoke to me or
not
what i do recall is that he kneeled down
before me
his face leveled with mine
i found my safe self
gazing into soft brown eyes
feeling bewildered and mute
when he was gone i felt his warmth in
the scarf
in the soft wine colored scarf that he
wrapped tightly around my head
i don't remember ice skating that day
or how we got home
all my memory holes now
is the snow
the kindness of a stranger
and my big brother lenny
[Applause]
our next reader will be
susan sante who will be reading my
father's dream by mary mccallum
[Applause]
uh
many years ago
my father had a dream about flying
it was so vivid to me that i told all my
friends about it
as time went on i repeated this story so
often
that i began to think of it as something
that had happened to me
my father was the manager of the camera
department at macy's
in the dream
he reached for the for the blue
ballpoint pen
in his breast pocket
to jot something down on his memo pad
when he pressed the springy
button
on top of the pen
he rose up into the air
no time at all
he was floating
above the glass display cases and
drifting toward the ceiling
he felt very pleased with himself very
happy
next he pressed on the side clip of the
pen
with some models that clip can make the
point of the pen retract
to his astonishment my father found
himself moving forward in a straight
line
by fiddling with the pen
he discovered that he could control the
speed and direction of his flight when
he touched the clip again he was able to
go backward he was elated
filled with a sense of enormous
well-being he began flitting around the
store and because he was so high up no
one could see what he was doing
emboldened by this new talent of his
he waved and smiled at some of his
co-workers as he sailed over their
departments
an airborne
mustachioed little man in a dark
business suit and a clip-on bow tie
none of the shoppers noticed him as he
dipped and dived above their heads
they were too busy looking at the
merchandise in the store
at breakfast the next morning he told
the family about the dream he said it
was a wonderful thing to be able to fly
like that to be powerful free and happy
someone had once told him that dreams of
flying
were a sign of good mental health
he felt that his dream
affirmed that theory
i have thought about my father's dream
many times over the years what i liked
most about it perhaps
was the way he seemed to expand
whenever he told the story the way his
face would light up
as he described the joy
and secret freedom of cruising along
above his co-workers heads
my father is
87 now
and he doesn't remember his dream of
flight
it was just one of the hundreds of odd
uncatalogued dreams that visited him
he talked about it for a few weeks
and then he forgot all about it
but the smallest things
impress a child
and his dream stuck to me i felt its
buoyancy took it and made it mine
in my version
i rise up pen in hand and watch waves of
sea grass
deep brown furrowed fields
the great plains and ferocious spring
rivers pass below me as i sail through
the air
i arc over shimmering african villages
and vast expanses of bluish snow
without feeling heat or cold
i see armies of emperor penguins on the
curve of antarctica waiting for spring
like mute statues
and roiling masses of humanity crushed
into subway stations
despite the shifts in geography my
imaginary landscape is forever and
always sunny
allowing me to track the wiggly shadow
of myself
as it speeds over the earth's pitted
craggy surface
i think my father was right about the
power of dream flight
while i can't say that these dreams are
indicators of my own sound mental health
i do know that i awake from them well
rested no matter how many miles i've
traveled
i feel unrestrained
capable and a tad sneaky
as if i'd been flying on the sly
[Applause]
thank you
our next reader is mary grace dembeck
who lives now in westport connecticut
but mary grace dembeck has written the
story of new york and it is called
an act of memory please
join us
[Music]
i was a young girl of 11 then living in
brooklyn
my father had died unexpectedly that
summer and times were suddenly very hard
for my mother my two brothers and me
my 18 year old brother had been in the
army for a year now
my other brother who was 13
worked as a delivery boy after school to
earn some sorely needed extra money
mama had worked for a while too after
papa died but had to stop when her
health started to deteriorate
papa had always made a big thing out of
christmas for as long as i could
remember the tree had always been at the
center of our celebrations
along with the creche and santa claus
there was a special little cupey doll
ornament with a red velvet circle around
it that papa always kept in its own
little box
every christmas when we were about to
decorate the tree
he would make a little ceremony out of
taking this doll out of its box holding
it up in front of me and saying
maria this doll is as old as you are
then you would hang the little cupi on
the tree
papa had bought that little doll the
year i was born and without planning to
it had become a small tradition in our
house for him to put my cupid ornament
on the tree first before any other
decorations
but this christmas we were to have no
tree
my mother was a very practical woman and
she decided that the tree was a luxury
we could well do without
i thought then with quiet but keen
resentment that it had never meant as
much to her as it had to papa anyway
and if my brother minded he didn't show
it
we had been to church that evening for a
visit and were walking back home in
silence
it was a beautiful clear winter night
but all i could see were the tree lit
windows we passed
their cheerful glow made my bitterness
even more intense because i pictured
whole happy families in those houses
sharing laughter exchanging presents
sitting at well-laden tables talking
joking
christmas had no deeper meaning for me
that night than all of this
and i knew that when we finally got to
our own house we would be greeted by
darkened windows and that once inside
our door we would be together yet
eventually alone each immersed in the
almost tangible emptiness that had come
to settle on us
as we passed my girlfriend's house which
was a few doors down from ours i noticed
that the lights were still on in her
living room
i asked my mother to please let me drop
in for a while just for a visit before i
came home
she said i could
only i never did go into my friend's
house that night
instead i waited until my mother and
brother disappeared inside our front
door
and then i impulsively turned and headed
for my father's shop about five long
avenue blocks away
it was a small grocery store on the
corner of 45th street and 11th avenue
for some reason i wanted to be there in
front of that shop that had meant so
much to him
even though it was now empty and for
rent it was as if somehow i would be
closer to him
there weren't many people about it was
very dark but i noticed for the first
time how beautiful the night was so cold
and crisp with such a sky full of stars
the trees in the windows still lit and
glowing didn't seem to be having the
same effect on me as early that evening
maybe it was the daring of being out and
alone at night for the first time or the
sense that i was going to be closer to
papa somehow
that worked some strange effect on me
whatever it was it seemed to quiet my
sense of resentment and grief
when i finally got close to the shop i
noticed these great odd-shaped masses on
the sidewalk nearby
i stopped dead in my tracks
my imagination started to take hold and
i nearly turned and headed back home
but something made me keep on going
as i got closer i realized that those
masses were not monsters at all but left
over christmas trees from the store next
to my father's shop
they were the trees that hadn't been
sold and were left to be picked up by
the garbage men or whoever it was that
carted off such things
i remember suddenly running to the pile
of trees and trying in the dark to pick
out the best one i could find i seem to
recall that the one i chose was huge
maybe 10 or 12 feet high but it couldn't
have been that big
anyway i grasped my tree grateful that i
had worn my thick wool and mittens and
began half-carrying half-dragging
my treasure home
my soul was full of christmas i knew
that papa was mixed up in all this
somehow
i don't know if i ever felt closer to
him than i did that night it was as if
he was in the stars above me in every
lighted window in the very tree i was
carrying
i don't recall if i met anyone along the
way
i guess i must have and if i did i must
have seemed an odd sight a young child
singing carol softly to herself lugging
a tree that was more than twice her size
but i know i wouldn't have cared what
anyone thought
when i got home i rang the doorbell and
was prepared to argue my tree into the
house if need be
my brother answered the door and his
startled look accompanied his amazed
where did you get that
we got the tree inside and he managed to
find the stand for it and we started to
put it up my mother came in and saw us
but said nothing
she took no part but neither did she do
anything to stop us
and though she knew i had not gone to my
girlfriend's house after all she never
said a word in reproof
when my brother and i were done we stood
back and looked at the tree
to us it was perfect without a single
flaw
i was so excited i could have stayed up
all night decorating it but my mother
insisted that it was late nearly
midnight and that we should all get to
bed
christmas was almost over i was sure
that she didn't approve of what i had
done
and i even started to feel guilty
suddenly realizing what grief that tree
might have brought to her and the edge
of my joy started to wear off
i got ready for bed my mind a confusion
of excitement and sadness
i went in to look at my tree one last
time before christmas was gone
my mother was standing in front of it
holding a familiar small box
i don't know if she saw me in the
doorway had she been crying
her hand seemed to tremble as she opened
the box she held the ornament up in
front of her not looking at me but at
the tree
maria she said almost in a whisper her
voice somehow different funny
this doll is as old as you are
and she hung the cupi on the tree
[Applause]
uh now i'm going to read a story written
by joe rizzo of the bronx
uh this one always amused me
tremendously it struck me as a kind of
new
episode of the honeymooners
it's called bronx cheer
al used to stand outside with his golf
sweater on always looking to play golf
so i went over and talked to him he said
are you ready to play golf
i said
not really
how about a game of pool down in your
cellar
so that's what we did we went downstairs
and started to play pool on this big
table that covered half the basement
but next to the pool table there
happened to be a wood column that
supported the floors above
every time i tried to use one of those
long pool sticks it would bump into the
wood column
i said to al
i can't make this shot because of the
column
al said
why not cut the sticks
i said
that's a good idea
and so that's what i did
then i had a better idea
i said al maybe we should eliminate this
column and put in a steel beam instead
he said that's a great idea
so al and i and the kids got into my
station wagon and drove to 138th street
and morris avenue
to pick up this
22-foot steel beam for the house
the beam was so long that it stuck out
of the station wagon
it kept hitting the street
bouncing up and down and sparking and
smoking
after a while the kids were yelling hey
daddy look the beam is on fire
al and i both looked
and sure enough we had to stop and cool
it off
once we got to the house we put the beam
in the driveway then we said
sorry it's so funny i can hardly contain
myself
then then we said
how are we going to get this big beam
into the house
i said that we had to cut a two-foot
hole in the concrete wall
then we'd be able to slide the beam
under the ceiling of the basement
so
we chopped the hole
i said to al that before we put the
steel beam in
we had to support the rest of the house
with jacks and supporting wood columns
we didn't want the house to collapse
before we took out the old wood column
we worked until midnight
we were tired and exhausted by then so i
went home
the next morning around six o'clock i
got a call from al help he said i think
there's something wrong
there's water coming down the steps
and the kids are yelling that they can't
open the doors to the bathroom and the
bedrooms to get out
i ran across the street
and there's al with his golf clubs and
his golf sweater
standing in front of the house and
yelling at the kids turn off the water
don't flush the toilet your mother's
downstairs on the table holding up the
chandelier and sealing with her hands
sure enough when i went into the house
that's exactly what i saw
arlene was up there on the table trying
to keep the chandelier and ceiling from
falling down al then ran upstairs and
opened the doors for the kids to let
them out i ran downstairs into the
basement and shut off the water
when i turned around i saw squirrels
jumping in through the hole we had cut
in the wall
the short cut down sticks were still on
the table and it looked like they were
playing pool with them
when i got upstairs my wife was there
yelling at me that it was our
anniversary
we have reservations in canada she says
did i forget
harry hurry we have to go
i looked at how and then at arlene he
was sopping wet and an al junior sliding
down the banister and at keith coming
down the steps backward on his knees and
he was something wet too
upstairs the girls were yelling where's
my clothes my clothes are all wet
so i yelled out at the top of my voice
stop
let's get arlene off the table and let's
try to clean up this mess so al can go
and play golf
i said to him i have to go on my
anniversary trip but when i come back
i'll try to put everything together
again
when i did come back of course arlene
had already put up some sheetrock on the
ceiling
she asked me to plaster it and then
paint the rest of the house and that's
what i did
but i still wanted to know what had
happened and al said to me just before
you came that day i had a carpenter come
in to shave and cut the doors to fit the
sagging house
i had known about this so quite
naturally when we leveled off the house
with our jacks and supports we
straightened it out and that's why
nobody could open the doors
you have to understand that this was not
a normal house
it looked like something from that old
comic book the old lady that lived in a
shoe with 40 kids looking out the
windows
but of course that didn't bother al
he would say to arlene don't forget to
plaster and paint the walls
and don't forget to pick out the color
and feed the kids before bedtime i'm
going to play golf
she would say
okay
but somehow
whenever she said okay
out popped another kid
there were kids all over the
place uh we've got a lot of stories here
from the bronx
and this one a gift of gold is by john
keith who now lives in san jose
california
but uh his story does not a gift of gold
it was the winter of 1937 just after
christmas the depression was still going
on but i was in good spirits at the end
of january i was going to graduate from
elementary school
i was just 12
younger than all the other boys in my
class and much smaller
my mother still dressed me in shorts and
when the cold weather came i wore woolen
knickers and knee-high socks
most of my classmates had given up
wearing shorts but even though they were
older and taller than i was they still
wore knickers
only a couple of the taller 14 year old
fellows had moved on to long pants
however for the graduation ceremony all
the boys were expected to dress the same
way
they were supposed to wear white shirts
navy blue knitted ties and dark blue
wool surge pants
when i asked one or two knickered kids
what they were going to do
they said that they were going to show
up on graduation day wearing long pants
i waited until a week before graduation
before i told my mother
i figured i'd better break the news to
her as gently as i could
i remember that it was a cold monday
afternoon
i had come home from school after
crunching my way over the treacherous
streets and crosswalk
there were deep ruts and tracks cut into
the thick layers of melted and re-frozen
snow
inside the house it felt warm and
comforting i put my heavy coat away in
the hall closet all the while inhaling
the tantalizing smell of fish being
fried in butter
i went into the kitchen for a glass of
milk one of the few luxuries of life in
our house
boy mom i said that smells good i love
fish
don't start bothering me for some now
she said the way you always do remember
if you have some now you won't get your
share of dinner
that was a little game we played always
with the same result
i would pester her until she swore that
i was driving her to distraction
then she'd give in and let me have a
generous sample
i'd invariably get my full share at
dinner
this time though i didn't put the game
in motion
mom i said about graduation yes she
answered shuffling the skillet onto the
burner
they're going to give me the first prize
medal i said
still working over the stove she looked
over her shoulder at me and smiled
broadly
that's wonderful babe dad and i will
both be there and we'll be the proudest
parents in the place
she must have seen by the look on my
face that something was wrong she turned
her back to the stove and said so
so i have to get long pants i said
it didn't take long to get the answer i
expected
babe we don't have the money for new
pants right now she said very quietly
you know that
okay i burst out but i won't go to
graduation plus i'm i'm running away
from home
i waited my mother shook the pan several
times and then turned over the pieces of
fish one by one
it was very quiet except for the sound
of melted butter sizzling in a pan
she turned to me
her outstretched hand held the spatula
on which she had balanced a piece of
golden fish
here she said cut one of the rolls on
the table and make yourself a nice fish
sandwich and if i were you i wouldn't
pack my bags just yet
we'll solve the pan's problem somehow
my mother watched me make the sandwich
she continued to watch me eat it
obviously amused by the way each bite
was accompanied by moans of delight
that ought to hold you she said
the following saturday when my mother
said let's go shopping i knew that she'd
solve the problem
mid-morning we bundled up against the
bitter cold that had settled over the
city and took the trolley that ran along
westchester avenue
we got off at southern boulevard the
best shopping street in the east bronx
our clothing store was just a couple of
blocks away we've been getting my pants
there for mr zenger ever since i could
remember
i liked mr zenger and i enjoyed hearing
him say as he always did
trust me sonny i'll give you the best
and with those pants you'll look like a
million dollars
but first we walked a short way down the
boulevard and stopped at a place i had
never noticed before my mother said wait
here
she opened the door and entered a store
a storefront that looked a little like a
bank
i read the sign over the door home
thrift and loan
she came out about 10 minutes later and
we went to the pants store
there mr zanger fitted me with what was
surely the greatest pair of 100
pure wool navy blue surge trousers ever
to be had in the whole world
mr zenger measured me for the inner seam
length and then sewed the cuffs while we
waited
the cost was three dollars and fifty
cents including the alterations
the new trousers were wrapped up in
brown paper and tied with string
i was holding the package tightly under
my arm when my mother went to pay mr
zenger
i saw her take a tiny brown envelope
from her purse tear back the sealed flap
and remove the contents
there were four brand new one dollar
bills inside
she carefully unfolded them and handed
them to mr zanger he rang up the sale
and gave my mother the 50 cents change
sitting next to my mother on the trolley
i had the window seat and looked out for
most of the ride
about halfway home there wasn't much to
look at rattling over the bronx river
bridge and as i shifted around to my
seat to face forward i glanced down at
my mother's hands folded across her
purse which was resting on her lap
it was then that i saw that the plain
gold wedding bang that had always
circled her finger
on her left hand was no longer there
[Applause]
um our last reader is going to be john
tuturo he's going to be reading the
title story of the book which is not a
story set in new york but i thought
everyone should finally understand what
this nutty title refers to
so john will be reading robert winnie's
story he now lives in bonner's ferry
idaho john ditura reading a gift of uh
i'm sorry uh i thought my father was god
[Applause]
these things happened in oakland
california at the end of world war ii
i was six years old
i didn't know what war was then but i
was aware of some of its consequences
rationing for one thing since i had a
ration book with my name on it
my mother kept it for me along with the
ration books that belonged to my
brothers
i remember the blackout
the air raid warnings
and the site of warplanes flying
overhead
my father was a tugboat captain and i
remember talk about troop ships
submarines and destroyers
i also remember my grandmother taking
fat to the butcher shop to be reclaimed
and going downtown to the federal
building to toss aluminum scrap into the
window wells on the sidewalk side of the
building
but what i remember most
is mr bernhauser
he was our backyard neighbor
he was especially mean and unfriendly to
kids
but he was also rude to adults
he had an italian plum tree that hung
over the back fence
if the plums were on our side of the
fence
we could pick them
but god help us if we got over the fence
line
all hell would break loose
he would scream and yell at us until one
of our parents came out to see what the
fuss was all about
usually it was my mother
but this time it was my father
no one liked mr bernhauser very much
but my father was particularly against
him because he kept all the toys and
balls that ever landed in his yard
so there was mr bernhauser yelling at us
to get the hell out of his tree
and my father asked him what the problem
was
mr burnhauser took a deep breath
and launched into a diatribe about
thieving kids breakers of rules takers
of fruit and monsters in general
i guess my father had had enough
for the next thing he did was shout at
mr bernhauser and tell him to drop dead
mr bernhauser stopped screaming
looked at my father
turned bright red
then purple
grabbed his chest
turned gray
and slowly folded to the ground
i thought my father was god
that he could yell at a miserable old
man and make him die on command
was beyond my comprehension
i remember that
ray
hinck lived across the street
and we were in the same grade and his
grandmother lived upstairs she was a
tiny old woman who always wore
high collar dress
she sat in the window with a pair of
opera glasses and kept watch on the
neighborhood
if we were good she would let us look
through the glasses and smell the rose
petals she kept in an alabaster jar on
her table
she said that the rose petals were from
germany and the jar was from greece
one afternoon i was allowed to handle
the precious glasses and was looking out
at the street
i had a cab pulled up
and a tall skinny sailor got out
he shook hands with the cabbie who took
a sea bag from the trunk
and i knew that it was my uncle bill
home from the war
my grandmother came running down the
steps into his arms
she was crying
i remember the stars that hung in the
windows of some of our neighbors houses
my grandmother told me it was because
someone had lost his son in the war
i was glad that we didn't have any stars
in our windows
that night we had a huge celebration for
uncle bill
i went to sleep feeling glad that my
uncle was home safe
i didn't think about mr burnhauser
anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
i just wanted to thank you all for
coming it's been a wonderful night and
i'm glad you're all here thank you
readers and audience alike thank you so
much
[Applause]
i thought my father was god is published
by henry holton company for more
information visit their website
henryholt.com
next week on public lives a look at the
life of american public